make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing our coverage
on weapons Plus and here's a funny thing
about this right weapons Plus is
probably the most important comic book
that Marvel is releasing right now that
no one's reading and it's kind of a
shame because there's so much going on
in in this whole weapons Plus comic and
here's my bet I would bet all the money
in my pockets - all the money in your
pockets that this is all going to go
towards the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
some form or fashion what other reason
is there to release and basically revamp
the entirety of weapons Plus if it's not
going to be incorporated into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's gonna make any
sense right because nobody was really
asking for and that's one of things we
talked about in the first video nobody
was really asking for like a revamp of
weapons Plus just came out of nowhere
now Marvel could be doing it of their
own volition but I feel like this is
gonna be a model cinematic universe kind
of thing but the idea behind this and in
the first weapons pleasent we had talked
about and this this one of the things
that kind of came out of this is weapons
Plus was historic leaves it was it was
kind of a weird thing right now
weapons Plus was originally just a
Wolverine thing and that was really all
it was then it turned it into with with
Grant Morrison's run it turned into
weapon 1 which was Captain America
running all the way up to whether an X
which is Wolverine and that's when the
official weapons Plus program came to an
end unofficially it continued on well
you got Deadpool you got the The
Stepford cuckoos with you know there
were basically clones of Emma Frost you
got all kinds of stuff that came after
came after world rank but the officially
sanctioned weapons Plus program as it
was operated as a joint venture between
Canada and the CIA was basically
disbanded like it was essentially gone
and so the funny thing about this and
what this did at least in the the first
the first video that we did is it
basically established that weapons Plus
was alive and well right like it was
commit was keeping on keeping on and the
extent of it we didn't know and we still
don't know but the crazy thing about
this is that that what it does is it
basically has like this weapon v
facility right this and this interesting
you could call it weapon v and that
really kind of seems to be the case it
sort of seems to be like a dual meaning
between weapon weapon you know v and
like weapon venom but what it does here
is it basically says okay essentially
like during the events of absolute
carnage when you know cletus kasady and
his various mini counterparts more or
less we're kind of terrorizing
throughout the city of New York and
attacking various places that what
cletus kasady has also been doing is
striking at the heart of these various
facilities because remember do you
overall theme behind absolute carnage as
a cletus kasady is going after anybody
who's ever
wanna submit right because anybody who's
ever once MBA gets this kind of codex
it's basically bonded to their genetic
material and in turn Cletus Kasady in
order to increase his strength to become
this wildly powerful being for what
seems to be the purpose of going
toe-to-toe with null the City of God all
really seems to be rooted in this idea
of gaining like these these codices
right these little codices that have
been bonded to people and so what ended
up happening is somewhere along the line
he attacked this Weapon 5 facility now
what this does is it jumps directly to
Clayton Cortez now here's thing about
Clayton Cortez right I would say about a
year ago Greg Pak had this really really
cool idea that marveled is kind of
wasted and the idea behind this was to
essentially introduced something called
weapon age now weapon age was a cool
idea like when it first popped up it was
a cool idea but like I was almost I was
considering covering it the problem was
I was looking at the entirety the marvel
landscape at the time and as soon as I
saw that come out my immediate thought
was Marvel's not gonna do anything with
that and the reason why is because what
it ended up turning into is Marvel doing
like this grand reshuffling right so it
was like during like the old you know
Dan Slott spider-man whoa when Peter
Parker went back to being spider-man and
it lasted like 12 to 14 issues and then
we got Secret Wars it was like okay so
Peter Parker's back but none of its
gonna matter because we're basically
getting Secret Wars so you're gonna have
to wait until Secret Wars is done to see
what happens with all of this of course
and we end up getting all-new
all-different amazing spider-man and so
on but you know looking at this I was
like okay I've seen this a million times
right like some character is introduced
basically it like the the the precipice
is what's gonna be like a huge
reshuffling at Marvel and usually Marvel
ends up wasting them and that's what
they did here they wasted Clinton Cortes
the idea behind this is that William
Stryker had his own kind of weapons bus
program going on not not tied into like
the overarching weapons plus thing but
basically his own sort of weapons
weapons Plus idea and that was really
predicated on the notion of we gotta
kill mutants so what does use weapons
press technology in order to do it and
so what ended up happening is is William
Stryker gathered together at the genetic
material of essentially the entire
x-force team at the time and then in
turn had them all bonded to Clayton
Cortes now there was Weapon beta and
then Weapon alpha or at least Weapon H
beta and then Webb and alpha or whatever
you want to call it H beta H alpha it
was kind of a weird thing but the idea
behind this is a Clinton Cortes is
basically Weapon alpha weapon age he was
the prime version and this is a guy who
essentially has adamantium bonded to his
skeleton
he's got the incredible whole concept
Rights was not unlimited strength but it
is like an insane amount of strength and
then he's also got Wolverines claws
right so he's a merger between two
of these characters along with some
other characters to write like Domino
different things like that and it's an
amazing idea like it is it is a super
cool idea but Marvel be Marvel wasted I
imagine as time goes on he may become
more prominent but the reality is that
weapon H is largely just a Greg Pak
concept that's really all it is but it's
just only Greg patch thing and so as a
result of this it's kind of crazy for
those guys who are new to comics want to
talk about this for a second so those
are guys who are new to comics Marvel
Comics operates very similar to like the
WWE from wrestling you have a character
who hits their peak usually the
championship belt and then for the most
part they just kind of fall to the
wayside to make room for the new guys
and that's basically what happened with
Greg Pak he's an incredible rider an
amazing writer but the idea here is that
he basically peaked for lack of a better
word with his run on the Incredible Hulk
but because it was selling so well what
was kind of like do your own thing man
so he just sort of gets shuffled off to
no-man's land but has total control over
what he wants to do right so he's like
to Starling with the infinity saga but
the idea here is a Clinton Cortes you
know some six minutes into this video
the idea is that Clinton Cortes ends up
arriving back at his family home where
at least where his family's kind of
residing at now this is an important
thing and the reason why is because
after he became Weapon Age and after he
fought the Incredible Hulk Wolverine and
then essentially left them and went to
go do his own thing he started going
from eaglestar facility to eaglestar
facility and essentially wiping out all
the records of himself the reason why
this matters is because eaglestar was
the the group that Clayton was part of
before he was forced into Weapon H and
eaglestar was basically just kind of
like this military contracting team
rather these guys would just go out and
take care of these various schemes and
that's actually where you end up getting
into this this little segment here is
that you end up in this scenario where
Clayton is basically confronted with
like his old boss where it's like we
were supposed to wipe out the whole
village you didn't swim so forth you
know and essentially they're there to
basically capture him though they'd like
to grab him and bring him in and the
reason for that comes by way of a guy
named dr. Andrew Bri now we'll talk
about Andrew Breen here in a minute
because at the moment he's just kind of
there and he becomes more important as
the story goes on or at least once we
get towards the end but what he does is
kind of give us this timeline of weapons
Plus and this is a very important
segment here and the reason why is
because in the first video was kind of
like okay here's the timeline of weapons
Plus based on what we know and what this
does is essentially clear all that out
and the cool thing about this is it
really kind of goes back to what we
originally talked about right this idea
that what you had in the early days is
you basically just kind of had this idea
that existed out there that
weapons Plus was basically the reason
for the creation of Captain America but
the problem was that once Captain
America was believed to have been dead
then the question became what do we do
next and so that kind of went into what
we talked about previously where you had
these weapons projects that were being
created weapons two and three and four
and so on and so forth but the big thing
was that in 1965 and this is what we
don't what we kind of talked about an
absolute Karnes has sort of been hunted
up but it really kind of gets
consolidated here which is pretty nice
but in 1965 essence the shield led by
Nick Fury along with a handful of others
ended up coming into contact with what
was basically the Grendel now of course
those of you guys who were following
Donnie Cates run and those of you guys
who were following absolute carnage are
aware of this but for those of you guys
who are not the Grendel is kind of like
this leftover remnant more or less of
when no the symbiote God was kind of
rampaging throughout the universe right
and so the idea was that was essentially
frozen on earth and and just kind of
stuck there this led into the concept of
the sim soldiers right so the idea of
like Rex Strickland and so on and so
forth over it it Donna Kate's venom run
as well as what we saw in the first
weapons Plus weapons Plus video and this
idea was that when you know with this
kind of culminating with Russia's
Department X which basically gave us
like the Winter Soldier it gave us the
Red Room which produced women like like
a Black Widow and Natasha Romanov and so
on and so forth because of the fact that
weapons Plus was for the most part only
really focusing on Russia when they came
across the Grindle what they realized
was the threat that's criminal host and
so as results that what they ended up
doing was basically extracting sections
of the Grindle off rather these small
little bits here and there which were
essentially you know the the precursor
to the Venom symbiote and what they
ended up doing was bonding it to guys
like Rhett Strickland right so this goes
into that whole thing following that
what we end up learning here and that's
what we didn't know before we ended up
learning here is that where it was
previously believed that weapons Plus at
least as part of it you know being a
kind of government sanctioned
organization was essentially gone the
reality is that's not the case that
weapons Plus still appears to be a
government sanctioned organization
albeit operating in like a super super
deep clandestine way but characters like
anti-venom like like Flash Thompson
he's a byproduct of weapons plus what
this is doing is basically grabbing the
entire venom mythos as it exists both by
way of what Donny Cates is doing as well
as people before him with the
introduction of like Flash Thompson as
agent venom and so and so forth and is
consolidating all of it down into a
singular timeline and that's a genius
idea because what this basically means
is that every iteration of the Venom
symbiote has appeared in Marvel Comics
as part of any kind of military team or
any kind of specialized operations team
like agent venom has all been sanctioned
and secretly controlled by the weapons
Plus organization and this is cool like
this is really really awesome because
from there like what it means is is it
literally kind of brings it all together
right in us that's one of the things
that Marvel's been focusing on a lot
recently it's creating more cohesiveness
not only that what we also end up
learning is that while Kirk Hart who's
basically the direct supervisor at least
was the direct superior of Clayton
Cortez when he was part of deagle Stark
while they had essentially gone
underground and they still exist as a
team they're now simply referred to as
like Mars team as opposed to like the
Eagle star group or anything like that
it's a way to kind of cast off the
previous name and then sort of operate
as kind of a blackops wet work team and
and to essentially stay off the radar
without anybody heating them up for like
contracts or anything along those lines
but the idea here is they were the ones
that were originally at the weapon VIII
facility when carnage first attack in
the beginning of the story and then they
basically made it out you know by the
skin of their teeth but they're
launching this attack yet again and
that's why they're bringing in Clayton
Cortez because Clayton Cortez is a heavy
hitter right like he's a big hitter and
so that's when you kind of end up
switching over to cletus kasady
who's actually sitting at a bus stop and
the idea here is is that cletus kasady
is ultimately drawn to these guys and
this is a cool little a cool little bit
of a revelation here right because this
is one of the reasons why tie-ins can
oftentimes really expand and make a
story a lot more interesting the Kudus
cassidy is traveling all over the world
to find anybody who's ever hosted the
venom Samia and the fact that these
these these you know former Eagles
starter know Mars team guys are
basically Sim soldiers meaning that
they're harnessing the power of the
Brendel means they all have coda seeds
and so as a results of that carnage is
going after them as well and that's the
cool thing is it's not just about
super-powered beings and it's
interesting to see because when this bus
comes cruising in rather this bus comes
flying in please Cassidy of course is on
it but he's killed everybody there and
this is one of the funny things that
goes on is because what this really
shows is that the in terms of the
government's perception at least weapons
plus his perception of carnage and what
is it he's capable of now they're
painfully ill-equipped right they're
painfully unprepared and the reason why
is because all they really know about
what carnage is capable of at the moment
is what they seen in the various footage
from the from the Battle of New York
because they're not really there as well
as the existing knowledge they have when
it comes to the simius but remember the
Grendel's
or cut above the rest this is not just
your regular venom Samia these guys are
really bred and and really the Grendel's
the Grendel concept itself is really
designed to be like this kind of uber
symbian which of course serves the the
will of no Allah symbiote God and so
with carnage walking around with this
sort of power and then in turn these
seven soldiers walking around with
something akin to this power your
initial thought is okay so simians are
basically weak to sonic and fire so
we'll use that neither of which work
right I mean neither of those bring him
down
the carnage just comes running out and
it makes sense right like the entirety
of absolute carnage would be kind of a
bust if it's just like so all they need
is fire okay we'll just go get pyro from
like the x-men and just watch how fast
he kills kills carnage you know like
pyro shows up and he's like somebody
give me a lighter you know or bring in
like like you know Ghost Rider or
anybody who can manipulate any kind of
hellfire and they would totally destroy
carnage and so it's cool to see that
that's not the case instead what you get
here is it's pretty knock-down drag-out
fight between Weapon H N and carnage
itself and this you know while this it's
not the grandiose thing ever this is
really Marvel just kind of proving a
point and showing us where carnage is
and the reason for that is because when
you read the absolute carnage of in
itself and you see him face off against
various characters it is interesting but
you can kind of chalk that up to the
nature of cons right there there really
isn't a whole lot this happen that it's
just like okay so just here's how far he
is above everybody else you have really
seen a whole lot of that yet and the
reason why is because a lot of the
conflict that you've seen has really
been confined like the spider base and
the venom of these characters right so
so it's big you're fine to like Miles
Morales and to like spider-man and to up
venom and things like that but these are
characters that that while they are
powerful in their own right seeing
carnage face off against the Incredible
Hulk was more of carnage outwitting The
Incredible Hulk
as opposed to out fighting the strength
of the Incredible Hulk and so again it's
kind of cool in that regard but what
you're seeing here is a knock-down
drag-out fight between what's
effectively the Incredible Hulk and
Wolverine merged into a singular person
and carnage now again there are
limitations here right Clinton Cortes
does not have infinite strength it
doesn't it doesn't really go on that way
and then that's when you start getting
to what's going on with dr. Breen and
dr. Breen what he's been doing is that
where he's been putting eye drops in his
eyes and the idea here is that he had
some sort of you know vision impairment
or something along those lines that he
needed those for you know hence the
reason he was wearing glasses the
reality is that he's been dropping the
Grindle into his eyes and the reason why
is because he said he wanted to see the
world the way the Grendel does and this
is kind of a cool thing because what it
does
it basically says that like you've got
the Grendel out there this this Grendel
Simbi it thing more or less is out there
and little pieces of it even siphoned
off over the years and that's where the
SEM soldiers come from but essentially
it sees the world in a different way in
so far as it's governed by a singular
ideology and that's what Breen had
picked up on breed had essentially gone
insane really whether this is like he's
absolutely lost his mind
but the idea here is that all he sees
when he when he puts you know has the
Grendel in his eyes is God is coming
right like God is on his way here
everybody's basically going to die and
it's essentially all kind of pointing to
this notion that no the symbiote god is
going to return which makes the most
sense it's really the direction
everything's going in and and after the
carnage would kind of be a bust if like
Knoll never returned right if it was
just like no he's not coming back he's
just been dead this whole time there'd
be kind of a bust right it'd be kind of
disappointing and so it's cool to see
that that that kind of things showing
back up here the result of this is that
because of the fact that Clayton Cortez
had never actually worn a a submit
itself and because Clayton Cortez
doesn't really care right he's kind of
out doing his own thing he ultimately
just ends up leaving Mars team to itself
right he's just kinda like whatever I'm
gonna leave and he ends up taking you
know taking taking somebody with him and
basically bailing out and that's
basically it right like he grabs a
stepmom and they end up leaving it's
kind of a funny thing because the
stepmom hates him but to see them kind
of reconcile is interesting but that
only really matters if you're reading
weapons right if you're not reading
weapon H none of that really matters to
you it's not really relevant to you the
idea and kind of a big take away this
seems to be coming out of this is weapon
age it looks like Clayton may end up
joining the Avengers but that's the
nature of right the nature of this is
that this guy's trying to go out and do
his own thing and doesn't really want to
be bothered with the rest of the world
he kind of wants to just stay off the
radar and stay hidden and so it would
make perfect sense if he didn't if it
was just like him fighting carnage which
is kind of a cool little thing in
reality if that's the case all this was
really designed to do by Marvel is to
get you know him out more into the
public eye and get people to read his
comics more but it is it is it is a cool
concept right because this entire
conflict was basically being monitored
by weapons plus they're watching this
this whole thing go down and ultimately
weapons plus season it's just an
interesting concept but at the end of
the day they're like we've got other
things you want to worry about namely
weapon 30 right like what man xxx and
this is kind of a cool thing because
it's like okay so like what other
weapons are they focusing on but the
overall gist behind this is that it
still continues the kind of mystery
behind the idea of weapons plus it gets
him use the mystery behind what's going
on with it and how all that's kind of
unfolding here's kind of a cool thing
here is
this guy this this person who's
overseeing it is actually just drinking
from a from a Captain America mug right
and it's kind of cool thing because well
you do have one of this guys off to the
side he's basically reporting to him my
question this would be really awesome
here if it turned out to be Stiebel evil
Steve Rogers from like secret Empire
that would be amazing gonna be like this
amazing revelation where he's basically
rebranding and reworking and running the
entirety of weapons press behind the
scenes I would love that but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]